this is the Dean the Dean Jew bismillah
alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
to another episode of the Deen show my
next guest his life was like an
action-packed thriller you don't have to
turn on Tony Montana Scarface we got
everything here from his life we're
going to try to uncover why this man
left that life that life of chastened
desires and passions in the whole
material world and being a slave to that
to being a slave to something else
all this and more here on the Deen show
with my next guest
Mujahid Fletcher here on the Deen show
we'll be right back this is the theme
the deegeu this is the day's the teacher
this is the main you know this is the
thing is the theme is the medium this is
the danger
this is the Salam alaikum peace be on to
you
y alaikum Salam peace be on to you how
are you hi min great jaimé jaimé yes
mr. J yes I used to call you her right
how are you I'm doing I'm great
all praises be to Allah I am great yeah
you're doing some wonderful work out
there by the blessings of God I mean you
know I'm just thankful to be able to
even be alive and you know do whatever
good I can now you just said something
interesting you thankful to be alive
because you've had some situations that
you almost didn't make it out of line is
this right Ryan yeah so that's what we
want to talk about one talk about your
life before you accepted this way of
life we have life of all the messengers
of God that way of total and complete
submission to the one God doing God's
thing not your own thing doing God's
will not your desires so you are a
person like many in a state of confusion
lost out there in darkness and now
you're someone who has peace and you're
a slave not to your passionate desires
but your slate to the one who created
you and you can identify with lot of the
other youth and other individuals adults
too who are still stuck in that
lifestyle of chasing the passions
desires working from Monday to Friday
party party work work and you know gangs
drugs throwing up this hand gesture
shooting here shooting there and your
life like I mentioned was like the life
of Tony Montana he was Colombian too
right
he was Cuban a qubit okay same
difference
yeah so you're Colombian right yeah
didn't will talk to us a little bit open
up tell us how was your life before
Islam mmm
I came to America when I was eight years
old and my parents came from Colombia
and I and I have to start by saying my
parents you know I never known of them
to drink or smoke in their life
my father was an agriculture engineer
and you know educated and the background
from from Colombia is a very strong
family oriented so when we came to
America we thought all these good values
that we had from our culture would
amplify and obviously many people come
to him
America and migrate because of better
opportunities when I was eight obviously
I didn't even know English
so I came as many of the immigrant you
know kids that that come went through
ESL English is the second language and
trying to identify and understand the
culture here of all the different
cultures together was challenging I mean
I had a you know a culture shock things
were done more individualistic here in
America you're kind of on your own and
you know you you basically handle what
you have to handle on your own but in
Colombia everything was done
collectively even in school you know an
elementary school so when I grew up and
was about the age of 1213 certain movies
started coming out like New Jack city
boys in the hood ministers society and
for anyone who knows about these films I
mean they're in an urban setting
basically in some of them in LA or New
York and it was uh basically the
lifestyle of gangster lifestyle it was
all about drug dealing and being close
to your friends to the point that if
somebody had a problem with them you
would protect one another so you've been
in an environment where you are majority
either african-american or Latino which
is the public school that I was going to
this movie New Jack city Wesley Snipes
being African American you know
portrayed the life of a drug dealer and
made some sort of gang and in front of
my eyes in school I saw a gang form and
they named it off of the film so it was
called New Jack hustlers yes the movies
gonna Jack City they called the New Jack
hustlers
at the beginning it was just like you
know anything you know I'm 13 years old
and before we knew it though Latinos
when they used to go to the restroom we
would hear stories that you know five
African Americans beat them up for no
reason just because he's Latino so it
became really hostile the whole
environment and a lot of these people
from this gang actually lived in my
apartment complex and we used to have to
walk to school you know we didn't have a
bus go into school so these people were
either behind this or in front of us
every day so as more Latinos began
been disrespected you know some someday
somebody walked up to Latino and just
spit on his face and somebody else went
and slapped a guy and I was like yeah
you know what was this about you don't
swat I mean my father always taught me
to respect people but also make myself
respected and so I used to always think
I mean I hope they don't come my
direction I mean my dad taught me how to
box when I was young were you in a gang
at this time no no this is the forming
of the environment of the gang and it's
funny because I never thought that we
would be anywhere close to again but
what happened was when more Latinos
began you know being violated you know
and assaulted a lot of Latinos came
together and they said well we have to
protect one another and and it made
sense you know and we kind of started
getting together and whenever we were
like 10 or 20 then these guys wouldn't
do anything and all of a sudden I
realized that it was it was dangerous
being by yourself because then if they
caught you by yourself it was something
called cuts being cut slipping meaning
that they could just Lynch you out of
510 people so then it had to become
official that you actually had each
other's backs or protected each other so
we came with a name called La Familia or
the family because you know as Latinos
you're from Mexico Colombia Puerto Rico
Cuba and you're all different as Latinos
so we had to get together on
commonalities and so we called this la
familia and before we knew it it became
again itself and because of my
determination of having some justice
let's say of people not violating one
another me being Stern about that they
asked me to be the leader of this gang
and started initiating people I mean you
know beating people down to come into
the gang making people be able to be
upright with what they said don't get me
wrong as a lot of good values right
loyalty keeping to your word you know
you know Brotherhood a lot of things
that that tied us together is just basic
human values that everybody shares this
give us an example when you said
violated in you get violated is that
what it is what what happens now
somebody comes to you and says look I
want to be a part of this left familia
look can you say Cosa Nostra
like Western astray is the same thing
family so something like that right yes
I want to be a part of this la familia I
want to be a part of this clique this
organization what do I got to do to get
it well you know usually people would do
it for protection for protection at the
beginning it was like a necessity but
then at that age you know 13 14 15 year
old kids you know being in the middle
school it starts becoming like a fad
yeah who are you with right and so
whenever we know that we can be
respected wherever we walk uh then
people want to be that way yeah and so
they would come and they said you know
we want to be down basically we want to
be part of the game so you make them do
a few jumping jacks the issue is there's
a weeding out process because if they
just want to come in because they want
to act cool then those need to be weeded
out this is not about being cool it's
about you know having loyalty and
respect and all these principles so in
order for them to prove themselves then
they're initiated an initiation is
basically about to two minutes two
million of three of us basically beating
him up yeah and people actually go
through that and now you feel part of
this family this is your family this is
now you're part of something you got the
protection you got your brothers pretty
much I mean this is a you know a fossa
you know false sense of a sense of false
sense of security everything based based
on false sense of security but that's
what happens in that realm and I mean I
remember you know being chased by ten
guys right running in my house and my
parents sitting there like what's wrong
with you and I'm like there's ten guys
outside what beat me up right and uh and
you're my father couldn't even
understand this it's funny because from
Columbia he walk out in front of the ten
guys and be like oh it's tonight y'all
just won one yeah I want to fight him
it's just one and he will used to say
well you know make them respect you
because he knew the sort of environment
we were living in I mean people were you
know began dealing with guns
there was a gunshots I mean one of my
friends houses you know they drove by
and they did a drive-by Anna's house
almost shot his you know little sister
you know and many things were crucial I
mean it was it was life and death you
know having guns at that you know at the
age of 13 and 14
that was a sense of security even to
protect yourself in your family so we
got guns involved yeah I have guns guns
you know nice knuckles that popped up
here and there but it wasn't even
respected really it was about you know
the majority of it was about being real
and being yourself yeah okay and that's
attractive for a lot of people because a
lot of people act like someone who
they're not especially at that age so
whenever you know who you are and you
can you know try to make yourself
respect it and if somebody wants to
violate you and you have enough what can
I say strength you know to tell them
well step outside and we'll handle it
and all that it's that sort of
environment but it's funny because it
all started from the films in the music
I mean gangster rap music gangsta rap
gangsta rap NWA I mean you know back in
the days and you know Ice Cube I mean
eazy-e
dr. Dre Snoop all of these names that
later on became you know entrepreneurs I
mean more time millionaires you know
they basically began around the time
that we were growing up so this whole
hip-hop culture formed and we were part
of that beginning phase basically did
you have a certain hand sign signal that
you guys would do you know it's funny I
never I didn't like that stuff yeah you
know I didn't like I didn't like people
kind of hyping things up as if it was a
game I always thought it was it was
serious you know it was it was not about
flashing and you know acting like
someone who you were who you weren't so
I used to realize like when friends of
mine had a problem sometimes they were
like somewhere in public and they used
to call me and say man look you know
so-and-so is over here they had a
problem with somebody's like 510 guys
and he's by himself so I used to be the
sort of person that used to go and and
walk him out of a public place mm-hmm
you know for protection sort of deal
yeah no time for all these you know
signs and everything but yeah some of
them you know they're like artists yeah
they draw up things and you know start
giving you know signals and signs which
actually for me I thought it was just
leaving traces you know of evidence yeah
and for later on for them to coin you
and signal you out you know which
eventually became that they had a book
of us with a sort of you know outline of
who was who and the sort of signals that
were
you know attached to who we were and so
on we're just getting started we got a
lot more so stay tuned we'll be right
back with more with Mujahid Fletcher
here on the deanship and if we're going
to worship something I figured I might
as well worship the Creator instead of
any of the creations now in upon
investigating the villages I remember
finding out the meaning of what Islam is
what Muslim is those who surrender their
self to God is a Muslim those who
surrender submit to God God's will that
is it Islam was pure it was just you
just pray to God your Creator I am not
afraid I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone
if Eliza
I'm not afraid to stand
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with
Jahid Fletcher talking about the past so
hopefully people in the present can
benefit and change for the better so
along with this lifestyle this tough
lifestyle
you got parting oh yeah draw bargain
yeah
you know rice abuse substance abuse
right so you know is there is there any
happiness there is there anything
because we really want to connect with
those who are still in this type of
lifestyle right say you know what these
people they don't identify this is my
family man these are people these are my
homeboys and you know this is all I got
and that like you said that false sense
of belonging that false is a security so
when you come across someone because
you've been there you've done that and
you you deal with someone who's still
chasing that that false sense of
security how do you deal with them first
and foremost I think you know as human
beings were a product of our environment
I never really thought of one day like
oh I want to you know start again it
even happened without us even
considering or understanding it right it
was a reaction to our environment that's
first and foremost whenever whenever
movies come out even though people think
it's art it can become reality okay so a
lot of people and nowadays when I'm
dealing with people you know they have a
sense of being like someone else because
they're scared to be themselves because
they don't they have an identity issue
and that's just because of the
environment that's stimulating them to
be all kinds of other things
okay so nowadays when I deal with
someone first and foremost I like to
respect where they're at instead of
downplaying where they're at that's the
first thing especially for someone in in
gang culture or even youth in general or
someone who has a false sense of
security of who they are because the
worst thing to do and you know we fail
to do this as parents many times it's
considered that even though we may want
you know our youth or someone to be in a
certain point we don't talk to them as
if they're there already we have to talk
to them based on where they're at so
whenever I deal with people and I'm
dealing with a youth right now he's 15
years old and he's part of a gang you
know here in Houston first and foremost
I have to respect the fact that he's
made a choice but then for him to
conscious
understand the repercussions and all I
can offer some advice based on you know
experience in certain people who took
that path and where it leads them now
it's on to them you know who they want
to follow and what they want to do but
giving people choices and options based
on experience I think is very valuable
before when we were growing up we didn't
have people that were older than us that
could actually connect to us you know
with our reality and be able to speak to
us at that level so it was always
downplaying it's like y'all shouldn't do
this what do y'all do that and whenever
you're young and you hear that you're
like yeah yeah you don't understand me
you don't understand where I'm coming
from
which makes you isolate yourself and
only people who understand you are your
friends so that becomes your family
basically you know sadly enough tell us
now did you see anybody living that
lifestyle or you live in a lifestyle was
there always something missing in the
back of your mind so you know I got a
change I got to get out was was there
something eating away at your conscious
most definite every single one of us
felt that because no matter what you do
you know you you feel as if you're
living this almost like surreal
lifestyle and it seems cool and when the
culture is there you kind of get many
things you know that you're supposed to
attract you know people from the
opposite sex right that's attractive
you know you attract a lot of things
that is supposed to be cool but whenever
that happens there's a sense of
something's wrong about what we're doing
and I don't really know how to change
but I want to change but nobody will
actually express that because if you
express that that means you're actually
getting soft you know what I mean you're
considering something that you can't
even figure out and nobody's figure it
out right so when you feel that you kind
of suppress it and you hide it and it's
interesting because in Islam you know to
cover up that true nature is actually
comes from the Arabic word kuffara you
know to hide basically and you know this
is what we attribute to a person who is
not connected to God right who doesn't
know their true nature so we may have
the nature of wanting to connect with
something we don't know if it's a higher
power or if it's actually really
philosophy because the way religions
expressed us it doesn't go according to
our environment many times you know so
even being Catholic from the Catholic
background you know I respect that
always God and and I knew that he was
basically watching and he could protect
me but you know whenever you're dealing
with situations you kind of just deal
with your environment you know and you
go with what's happening and day-to-day
you do certain things that you regret
the next day but it's like oh well
that's life you know you live to die
basically there's no real sense of
purpose and so that does eat away and I
think I talked to a psychiatrist friend
of mine you know asked why do people
take drugs and you know alcohol for me
to understand why we did that in the
past even he said it's because you have
an illness or something you want to cure
and you self-medicate so I would say
that you know taking drugs and all of
that is kind of self-medicating you know
an illness that you have from within and
and that's what was happening before and
many people who are dealing with that I
mean they could attest to that
anybody who drinks and wakes up the next
day they know they're just not happy
about what they did you know many times
turning-point
now what was the turning point in your
life that you found out what the purpose
of life is why you're here in this world
when did that happen there was a there
was a point in time that was drastic for
me and change and that was the fact that
my parents sent me back to Colombia
to South America when I was 16 years old
I was coming down from a party one night
and some individuals literally tried to
take my life and I had to defend myself
and I didn't know if in the altercation
people had gotten hurt and I could
possibly even you know go to jail or
something so I came home bleeding and
details left aside you know I told my
parents what had happened and it was
going to scale up from there I mean
either they were you know next time they
were truly going to kill me or the
opposite was true so they sent me to
Colombia and in that period of time it
led me to think and ponder about life
and it's funny because people think
Colombia is about cocaine and it's so
you know dangerous I saw my life change
in Colombia because it was so natural
and the people are so good and
welcoming and education was highlighted
I began to do very good in my grades I
was top of my class I became an English
teacher at the age of 16 which was
unheard of you know I had a very good
job I was making my own money and going
to school and and being very independent
I learned independence in Colombia when
I came back I wanted that sort of
lifestyle but it was tough in this
environment you know eventually I kind
of got sucked back into the environment
went back to partying went back to doing
certain things not gangs because that
was like played out already I was older
but I began to look into religion for
answers and I was going to different
temples I went to the Buddhist temple
Hindu temple I I went to different
churches you know start analyzing why
why are they different Bibles and Hum
Dil I mean in the midst of all that
searching I found Islam and that aslam
came to me at a point in time where I
really felt like you know I may die and
I didn't I didn't even know where I was
going and I usually eat away at me and I
used to think to myself you know why are
we even here I mean just we live and die
a mass some material gain and just leave
it you know so alhamdulillah after
leaving a club with an individual that
really wasn't practicing Islam that I
grew up with he was looking at the at
the liquor that he was drinking and he
said he couldn't believe he was doing
that after having gone to Mecca and I
didn't even know what Mecca was and when
he explained to me I became very curious
and he said you can speak to my mother
she was a Christian nun and she became
Muslim and from there on I just went
spoke to her she gave me a Quran I
started analyzing and reading and then I
started seeing myself leaving habits I
didn't even want to go out anymore
I started stopping my relationship with
friends that I had that I knew were no
good and eventually when I embraced
Islam from that day on I knew I never
wanted to drink another drink in my life
I never wanted a smoke I never wanted to
harm my body because I realized that it
was a blessing you know to be able to
see life from the perspective of Islam
because it's like a lens that clarifies
life for you and so I started seeing the
clarity of life and I said this is what
I've been looking for
all my life now all I have to do is live
up to it and hamdulillah you know all
praise is due to Allah when my parents
saw the change my father became with
some three months later your father also
accepted yeah he became Muslim at the
age of 57 they thought nothing could
change you know in life
my girlfriend that looked into Islam
with me at that point in time also
became Muslim a week after we got
married a month after my mother accepted
Islam about three years after my
mother-in-law accepted Islam that day my
first daughter was born my little
brother in law at the age of 16 years
old accepted Islam a lot of my gang
rival you know people who I had problems
with accepted his arrival / yeah yeah
you know so gangsters I mean you know
September 11 hit three months after I
became Muslim I was asked to speak in
front of the news in Spanish
specifically and then in English and we
saw throes of people becoming Muslim
just because we're able to be
straightforward about the information
like this many people don't know about
Islam you know it's beautiful that a
show like this can be able to you know
give this message you know to people I
mean it's not it's not a gimmick you
know this is not a it's like a get quick
get-rich-quick scheme you know a
religion sort of deal this is real
gradual change and it really builds
character
yeah yeah definitely definitely and
we're going to be back I'm going to take
some questions from our live studio
audience
here on the Deen show we'll be right
back I am NOT I am not afraid to stand
alone if Allah is by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid of
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone
I solo India's adorable solo
yeah nah so classic I would go to my
room lock the door prostrate and cry
thank God you know me better than myself
show me the right way and I will not
look like I will leave everything behind
a lot of that greater and it creates
everything it gives intelligence to
people
Mohammed is one of the lessons and since
we got back here on edition would take
some questions from our live studio
audience here that your question is
please for John Fletcher go ahead uh
call her Salaam alaikum
um brother Ajay you've done a lot of
Dawa to people face to face and can you
talk a little bit about the difference
between doing Dawa face-to-face and
doing it like electronically you know on
something like the Deen show Aslam in
Spanish masala so appreciate it so the
question is about that Allah that Allah
and the Arabic language means to call
someone or invite someone to Islam so I
in in Dillon or engaging with people and
speak into them face to face
there's a lot of qualities that exist in
regards to the people the people's
reaction regarding how you deliver the
information right I can see we're
excellent
yeah so how they're they're wanting to
see if you're anxious about what it is
that you're saying are you like trying
to sell them pin them down defeat their
arguments you know people really want to
see if you're legitimately really care
about if you're true and sincere the
fact that you want some good for them
it'll impact the way beyond any word
that you even say and that's not
something that can even be expressed it
is only something that's felt and when
understanding that there's another human
being and he has a soul and that soul
was created by the same creator that
created you and that's always going to
have to go back and answer in regards to
what he or she did then now there's a
higher respect for that individual it's
not even what he does or who
what color he is his way beyond that so
I think that deeper sense of dealing
with each other as humans really helps
on the on the personal note now when
dealing with media and you know I've
been fortunate enough to study media and
we utilize audio and video multimedia my
field interestingly enough it's multiple
ways of sending messages
that's what multi media means media is a
way to communicate with people sometimes
people have an easier time sitting in
front of YouTube for example or watching
a video because is less what can I say
it's not going to hold them to account
based on what they hear right so their
guard is down and also they can't really
argue based on emotions that they have
so if you say something about someone's
way of life or someone's religion they
may actually feel that you're talking
about their mother or their grandmother
who taught them this it's like how dare
you you know how dare you say my mother
taught me what was wrong that's the
feeling but you know when someone
watches a video they can't really argue
about that so they may be more
susceptible to listening analyzing and
if there's an email of the email all
these emotions are out of the way
because you know how much emotion can
you put into an email that sort of thing
so I think for different mediums there
are different styles of communication
and understanding those styles and
understanding how to deliver the medium
the message is very powerful because now
you have so many multiple ways of doing
something and it's beautiful I mean I
think it all has its its each
perspective within within wisdom
basically how to utilize it and we're
going to go ahead and grab another
question here from this young man here
how are you doing young man under now
are you go ahead Roma dad we're glad
that you here and my question is I
understand that you probably looked at
your past as a loss Pantera saved you
from that past however I can see that
you probably see some positive things in
your past that really benefited you
right now at being a Muslim and what are
these things that you can pinpoint for
us that's a good question because we
understand in Islam that basically there
is a concept of destiny
in Islam and the concept of destiny is
the fact that God
the Creator the heavens and the earth he
basically chooses for us only what is
best if we have really understand who he
is his decree has wisdom in it
so who knows maybe a lot of what I lived
in the past led me to want to connect
myself more to him now no telling if I
wouldn't have lived the sort of
experiences that I lived in the past if
I would have that sort of you know a
desire to do some good because some
people asked me after I became Muslim
you know I you know I started an
organization called Islam in Spanish you
know started not only telling people
about Islam but trying to live is where
some people have said where's that
energy come from you know where do I get
inspiration from sort of thing and I I
would say that is it's like a catch-up
game I'm catching up because I you know
I lost so many years of my life doing
certain things but then considering I
don't think it's a loss it was it was
something that happened then that led me
to want to know the truth I wanted to
know something that was straightforward
I didn't like people telling me things
that didn't even you know people just
give opinions about life right like
everybody knows what's best for you
I started not liking to follow human
beings but if you don't follow human
beings how are you going to live right
and so I was like I've pushed that out
of the way but why did I know that
because of so many experiences that I
had loyalty Brotherhood all of these
things that we were talking about in
game culture when looking at Islam and
becoming a Muslim you gain true
Brotherhood now you love one another for
the sake of you know the one who created
you
Brotherhood now in the Muslim community
with the affinity that we worship one
God and in society in general is the
sense of brotherhood because of you know
we're humans so it's a sense of
brotherhood in humanity so now these
notions that I learned you know and and
the sort of difficulties or obstacles I
faced the things that urged me to to
want to kind of obtain a higher sense of
living I found that in Islam so I mean
loyalty truthfulness you know a sense of
family likelike a human family I mean we
find Muslims come from all over the
world and I don't think I would have
known so many people
from so many different backgrounds and
colors and languages if I was in a
Muslim because when you not Muslim you
only kind of hold to your own so there's
so much I mean that I've benefited from
and not being Muslim and living the
lifestyle that I live that uh that
encouraged me now more and more to be
able to you know seek out those things
as a human being that I found in Islam
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here are just not
anyone's job to go into someone's heart
to change their heart your job is to
tell people what the truth is and the
alley of it is while we're sitting here
while I'm sitting here constantly paying
for the disease the cure was free
[Music]
people out there because we love our
brothers in humanity and everybody has
the potential to submit to the Creator
alone without any associates without any
partners is what Islam is calling you to
do it's calling you to submit to the one
God and to do good to do righteousness
but some people have many misconceptions
so just in short how do you deal with it
because you're out there you're inviting
people to purposed if you reflect about
the purpose of life you're given them
the invitation but some people they feel
look Islam is barbaric
Islam is about oppressing women Islam is
backwards what do you say to them you
know with with anything in life if you
want to judge you have to go to the
source of what you're trying to judge
and I was keen on wanting to know about
Islam based on the sources of Islam so
anyone who is saying anything about
Islam they need to check their sources
first and foremost and whenever people
say something about Islam and they say
something like it's barbaric or is this
or is that always question and ask them
how do you know where did you get that
information from and the majority of the
times they'll say from the news and so
based on the news if it was true always
then I should be selling drugs because
I'm Colombian Yeah right
that's who I'm supposed to be right and
and all that and there's stereotypes for
every sort of you know demographic and
people but it's so superficial you know
when people want to be real about
something they need to research and they
need to study and they need to ask
people who are qualified and whatever it
is right if you want to fix your car you
know you don't just go in you know
follow someone's advice who doesn't even
understand the principle of that concept
you go to a specialist you know in Islam
we have people who are qualified to have
people of knowledge basically and I
remember going to a mosque and asking
questions the same way I went to a
Buddhist monk you know and all that I
think people need to be more open to
dealing with people who are different
than them and if people want to embrace
a sense of within themselves they have
to begin by expanding the realm of of
research you know if some people are
always like whatever I think is
right for those sort of people I mean
what can you do they can read possibly
but if people read and then go and find
out who the Muslims are anybody who
finds a Muslim and understands what
Muslim is based on his attitude his
character will understand that I mean
we're human beings we all make mistakes
right now I'm not going to say that you
know there's not Muslims that are you
know doing things that are wrong I mean
there's Christians that are doing things
that are wrong and Buddhist because you
know that's human beings but we don't
blame religion on that we blame the
individual possibly for having some
shortcomings so people should research
about Islam and when they find what
Islam has to offer based on the to
sources which is the book the Quran
which is a final revelation sent from
the Creator that is an earth confirming
the Bible the Old Testament the sums of
david the psalms of you know so many you
know abraham it's a confirmation of all
the scriptures and then when they want
to know how to implement that book we
look at the example of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him which is you
know brothers with Jesus and Moses and
Abraham and Ishmael and all of them
their brothers in faith in the same
faith none of them came to tell people
other than there's only one God and none
has the right to be worshipped except
him alone follow me every single one of
them are to be followed and if we follow
them
we'll find that they never pray to
anything other than the Creator and so I
think for sincere people that really
question about life Islam is by far I
mean you know the best option but they
have to discover that on their own
because nobody can do that for them and
it's only through God's guidance and I'd
recommend people to really and sincerely
be true to themselves and ask the
Creator to guide them to whatever is the
truth regardless of what it's called
regardless of what color it comes in and
who practices it and if a person sincere
in that way we have total confidence
that you know whoever the creator of the
heavens and the earth guides nobody can
lead them astray and whoever is led
astray none can guide what other than
him so they have to interest in him
first and foremost we're getting a
signal that we're almost out of time I
just got to get one more in the person
says you know what I'm a good person and
I believe in God but I do
don't want to follow any organized
religion I'm a person of science would
again so have you heard this yes for
sure most definite a lot of times
there's blanket statements like that
because the person is possibly avoiding
something that they saw that they didn't
like from a religion right so I remember
looking at the aspect for example in
Catholicism right it doesn't make sense
to me for example if I say if
Catholicism is an organized religion the
the very thought that the most purest of
women become nuns those are the good
women they become nuns meaning they
can't marry okay because they're pure
they gave their life to God then you
have the purest of men they become
priests right the best men and they
can't marry so logically you analyze and
you say well the only people reproducing
are the bad people how does that make
sense
I don't like organized religion then you
understand I rather just like at random
good people and bad people mix better
than just you know bad people not mix
yet yeah this and so if people send this
sort of thing from a religion then
obviously but whenever you look at Islam
has so much order that any human being
will feel like I'm glad I finally found
order science can give you facts about
the creation but that creation has a
creator and the creator can explain in
context from his perspective what the
creation is not only scientific facts of
the material realm but things that are
deeper and signs so that people can
ponder about another life that is beyond
this one and when you know there's so
many parables about creation you know
the grass basically we all see it die
and then we see that it comes back up
you know when it has water and
everything these are signs of like a
human being who dies and then he goes on
to live again you know afterwards in
another life and so when we look at
Islam we look at the creation and we see
the signs you know and Allah mentions
many times in verses and basically the
men who ponder you know men this is
clear signs for men who you know who
ponder who men of understanding you know
men who contemplate so this sort of
reason
in you know has to be instilled in a
human being
voluntarily many people have this
involuntarily and they just hide it and
they don't want to seek answers for the
person who wants to seek answers Islam
is is by farming you know the best
choice and I tried looking everywhere
and tried everywhere I tried to negate
Islam as much as I try to negate every
other religion and I had that literally
after like one year of researching about
Islam trying to find the negative side
or the problem with it you know I just
gave up and that's what Islam means it
means to surrender it's like when you
give up it's like yeah I give up I can't
you know it's like you try to throw
stones and you can't hit it and so I you
know that's when you submit and you say
you know Allah is the only one where you
worship Muhammad is a messenger and this
where life basically is a way of life
for all human beings that is pleasing to
God on the day that we stand in front of
him basically after our death to be able
to be given either another life which is
way better than this one which is
paradise or be punished for the fact
that we didn't do what we were supposed
to do which is the Hellfire and we
always seek refuge in God basically from
this notion of ending up in the ladder
and the Hellfire because it's a place
nobody wants to go and if people deny
that they may do it now but it will come
a time where it will be a reality and so
all these books that were sent down and
all these messengers that were sent
through our time was to inform people
and there will be people who will accept
and there will be others that don't so
we also have to have tolerance basically
for you know every human being and their
choices but we can all only give the the
information basically and we're
entrusted with that due to the fact that
after the Prophet Mohammed we understand
peace be upon them there will be no
other messenger sent to humanity so it's
on to people like yourself myself and
many of the people who have understood
their message to share it with humanity
and after that you know Allah will guide
home so ever He wills in the last minute
that we have tell us a little bit about
your organization how people get in
contact with you to learn more to get
involved excellent um-hum did Allah was
fortunate to be the founder of an
organization called Islam in Spanish
Salam in Spanish yes and the website is
Islam in Spanish oh our G this is for
Latinos or people who speak the Spanish
language because I saw that there was a
void
there was an even material when we
embraced Islam hamdulillah we have the
Quran now in 26 CDs that we've produced
much of the information that exists in
the Arabic language and even in English
we have basically now in Spanish
worldwide so we dedicated that for a
group of individuals that didn't really
have the message and we've seen hundreds
of people martial I embrace Islam
because of that but then now also that
led on to being able to establish a
place locally here in the Houston area
called the Andalusia social and
educational media center and the website
for that is under Lucia Center dot o-r-g
in this Center is kind of a hub for us
to be able to deal with a lot of the
people who we've been dealing with over
a period of years which is the youth
people who are new to Islam who are
making the transition into Islam Latino
communities we do a television show
there now for Islam in Spanish where we
benefit people through workshops and so
on and and basically people who are not
Muslim you know they need a place that
is not necessarily a mosque or a place
that is a religious setting they need a
social setting you know so that they can
go be themselves but at the same time
interact with people like ourselves who
are Muslim and we can dialogue and you
know we have film screenings there was a
PlayStation 3 tournament happening today
with the youth and many things that are
social but always within the context of
the good and a positive message always
involved so hungry Ladd is a you know a
new project that we hope basically to do
shows like this hamdulillah we had you
today and I interviewed you a
hamdulillah there at the end of the CF
Center you know and we hope to be able
to produce films short films right now
this is kind of a next project for
myself as an individual I'd love to
produce meaningful films that show live
change in moments and turning points so
that people can be inspired to be able
to reason in question about life
sometimes leading them to look into
Islam look into themselves you know a
lot deeper and so on so now we have a
whole production studio hakeem olajuwon
is one of our supporters and many others
I mean the Muslim community in Houston
has been great and people all over the
world
use of Estes as you know and and many
others you mentioned Muhammad oddly
there's many good people who have done
work that really their prayers and their
support and networks and everything I
mean have really helped us and we're
working with the city of Houston as well
interfaith ministries dealing with
people of different religions I mean
there's a lot going on and this project
literally has just kicked off maybe
about two months ago
so you know we hope you know that Allah
blesses it to be a source of good you
know for Humanity in general and you
continue with the wonderful work you're
doing may God Almighty Allah reward you
thank you so much for being with us
thank you so much for having me I really
appreciate it I understand Allah bless
you for your work I mean YouTube thank
you so much thank you and thank you out
there I hope you got to benefit from the
jaw heads story and I hope that you
continue to tune in here to the Deen
show and if you want to learn more about
Islam call the number on the screen 1
800 662 Islam pick up a verbatim the
verbatim Word of God the Quran read it
today and we will see you next time we
started with peace we on with peace
until next time peace be unto you